in this part of the world when we hear
Kashmir we're more likely to think of
Led Zeppelin than what some called the
longest and largest military occupation
in recent history but is it actually a
military occupation following years of
protests political organization and
hinds civil unrest the British decided
in 1947 was the year to leave India
after almost two hundred years of
colonial rule part of the plan for the
subcontinent independence was to
partition the country India for the
majority Hindus and East and West
Pakistan for minority muslims who had
been seeking political representation
for decades this meant we not only saw
the biggest mass migration of the 20th
century but also the bloodiest with over
1 million believed to have lost their
lives so where does Kashmir fit into all
of this well in 1947 Kashmir was an
independent state and the leaders had a
choice and where it could go and it had
a majority Muslim population but was led
by Hindu Maharaja Hari Singh but instead
of following suit with other Muslim
majority states Singh would go on to
join India that triggered a seven
decade-long conflict between India
Pakistan and once-in-a-while China and
while the United Nations has stipulated
that a vote should be held in Kashmir to
determine the state's future guess what
neither Indian nor Pakistan has ever
allowed it today Jammu and Kashmir is
India's only Muslim majority state most
of the unrest that we hear about occurs
in the part known as a Kashmiri Valley
part of your original state is with
Pakistan it's called Azad Kashmir China
and India both claim oxide chin in the
most northeastern part of Kashmir
now Kashmir holds strategic symbolic and
resource importance for all three
countries for Pakistan Kashmir is water
Pakistan is one of the most water stress
countries in the world and Indian
control of Kashmir means Indian control
of water that Pakistan desperately wants
India depends on Kashmir's Muslim
majority character which lends
legitimacy to its claim as a secular
state for Pakistan the claim to Kashmir
also lends legitimacy to the two-nation
theory that Muslims in India needed
their own state and for China
control over northeastern Kashmir means
control of a region that connects Tibet
with a Muslim Uighur province of
Xinjiang India also sees Kashmir as a
buffer zone between itself and Fox
in China as a result India and Pakistan
have fought a total three wars over
Kashmir the most recent being the 1999
Kargil war while India claims that Jammu
and Kashmir is an integral part of India
its grip on Kashmir has been bolstered
by its strong often violent military
presence in the state and the movement
for Kashmiri independence from India has
only grown so is India's presence in
Jammu and Kashmir a military occupation
like Israel's occupation of the
Palestinian territories not under
international law but many Kashmiri 's
would say it definitely feels like it
with hundreds of thousands of Indian
security forces in the region
checkpoints curfews Vonn crackdowns on
protesters and disappearances are just
some of the hallmarks of India's
military presence in Jammu and Kashmir
for India continuing a military presence
in Kashmir has been seen as necessary to
deter violence from Kashmiri separatists
it's also seen as necessary to deter
Pakistani involvement and support for
armed fishmeal resistance something the
Pakistani government has also admitted
to one-third of those killed since the
beginning of Kashmiri separatist
violence in the late 80s are believed to
be civilians the number of total
civilians and combatants killed since
then has varied from 47,000 to 100,000
depending on your sources so it's time
for all Kashmiri is to finally have the
opportunity to vote for the course of
their own future